RICH HYNDMAN: This week's
Android Developer Office
Hours, live from DroidCon,
Holland this week.
We're in a very nice corridor
that they've put us in outside
the main hall.
There's lots of interesting
talks going on in there.
Something's different.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
we wear the stupid hats.
Or amazing hats.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
As usual, I'm joined by--
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
lent us some awesome headwear to
make this show a little bit
more ridiculous.
I mean, awesome.
RICH HYNDMAN: Epic.
As normal, I'm Rich Hyndman.
And I'm joined by--
NICK BUTCHER: Nick Butcher.
MATT GAUNT: Matt Gaunt.
SPARKY RHODE: Hey, guys.
NICK BUTCHER: Just
in time delivery.
We have one Sparky Rhode.
SPARKY RHODE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: We'll actually
let you do some sign-ins so
you can tell what's going on.
Hopefully this week will
be slightly more
sane than last week.
And this guy.
Say hi to the internet.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hopefully
this week will be
a little more sane.
Last week got a little bit
crazy over at Devoxx.
We couldn't really hear
anything anyone said.
But we've got a whole
lot of questions in
the moderator's way.
You can find that at
developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
And [INAUDIBLE].
Hey, Sparky.
Good to see you again.
Hey, Yossi.
Good to see you.
[INAUDIBLE]
from Munich.
And Paul, isn't it?
Paul Hanson as well.
It's good to see you.
Hopefully you've got some
questions for us today, Paul.
Have we got anything to talk
about this week before
we jump into the--
We did so much last week with
all the SDKs and APIs and puns
everything.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, it
got a bit nasty.
Wasn't it?
RICH HYNDMAN: It got a
bit much for us guys.
This week [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Nexus 10 back in
stock in the UK, and probably
out of stock.
SPARKY RHODE: [INAUDIBLE]
should be arriving
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Nexus [INAUDIBLE] shipping
people, very exciting.
SPARKY RHODE: Has anyone asked
where you can get Nexus 4?
NICK BUTCHER: Copy
at my house.
RICH HYNDMAN: I would say
that's a bit expensive.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's rather
[INAUDIBLE] today.
Maybe
google.com/store/devices, probably.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: [INAUDIBLE].
How can I get a hat like--
RICH HYNDMAN: How can
you make a hat?
MALE SPEAKER: Cruzerlite.com
RICH HYNDMAN: Cruzerlite.com.
NICK BUTCHER: Is that I-T-E?
MALE SPEAKER: C-R-U-Z,
L-I. It's on the hat.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey [INAUDIBLE].
And we have a big
Android barbecue
kicking off here in about--
two hours, Todd?
Is it the first one?
Has this ever happened before?
First ever big Android
barbecue.
NICK BUTCHER: Inaugural
Hope I don't get
food poisoning.
MALE SPEAKER: I haven't seen
the actual barbecue yet.
RICH HYNDMAN: You should come
around so they can see you.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Speaking of
barbecue, these two are also
making a barbecue.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: What's that?
MALE SPEAKER: He had
a barbecue set.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah,
just got it.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, nice.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, what?
That's pretty epic.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
from Andrew Bell.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
And also this one.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
April.
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, let's get
some content into the show.
And has anyone inside
the Hangout got a
question for us this week?
Going once, going twice.
MATT GAUNT: Anything on NFC?
NICK BUTCHER: Drum roll.
PAUL HANSON: I've got one.
It's just these lock
screen widgets.
Do you have full access to NFC
and other resources on the
lock screen widget?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
PAUL HANSON: No?
OK, cool.
I didn't think so.
NICK BUTCHER: No, they're still
remote user access.
So only remote-able objects,
you can put inside it.
PAUL HANSON: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's-- yeah--
pretty much just the same as a
desktop widget in
most respects.
You just set the flag to say
whether you want desktop or
lock screen or both.
It's like a manifest in
the declaration--
Winnie the Pooh's just joined
us-- in the declaration of the
lock screen widget.
And I think so far the abundance
of lock screen
widgets have been clocks, which
use a single font weight
throughout.
NICK BUTCHER: Boo.
Anyway, in fact, I think
the [INAUDIBLE].
Isn't the NFC chip powered
down until
screen on and unlocked?
RICH HYNDMAN: It may well be.
NICK BUTCHER: So I
believe that was
certainly the case before.
I don't think that's changed
in [INAUDIBLE].
I don't know off hand.
But yeah.
That reason, I don't think--
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, for that
reason, [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL HANSON: That sounds good.
Thank you.
It's what I expect.
Thanks, guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: No
problem at all.
Yossi's joined twice,
I believe, now.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, Yossi.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I just
lost my Wi-Fi.
So this one will drop soon.
RICH HYNDMAN: Do you
have the moderator
there for us, Sparky?
SPARKY RHODE: I do.
We have a bumper crop of
moderator questions this week.
I count, I believe, 17
moderator questions.
RICH HYNDMAN: You count or you
looked at the number which
tells you how many there are?
A handy thing.
SPARKY RHODE: But I actually
counted them.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPARKY RHODE: Leave it to me to
use an order and operation
where a constant time
will suffice.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, then.
Let's get straight into our--
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
"Best practices for unit
testing Android apps?
What is Google using, and
what's in the pipeline?
Guice, Maven, JUnit, Robotium,
UI Automator Viewer, or
other?"
NICK BUTCHER: To come to do this
Hangout, I just walked
out on a talk on testing,
unfortunately.
So [INAUDIBLE]
do you want to give a plug to
the official guidelines first?
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
I gave a link to the
developer docs and
that was my only answer.
NICK BUTCHER: So the question
is, what is Google using
internally?
And that tends to vary by app.
So most people are using their
normal JUnit stuff.
I've been hearing a lot about
Mockito, gaining a lot of
popularity since Mockito added
support for mocking out
Android objects.
That's getting really,
really popular.
There's also the new UI
Automator framework, which our
internal testing
team developed.
And then that's just been
open sourced in the
latest tools release.
One of my statements is a
service called testdroid.com,
who offer an awesome recorder
service to essentially
generate Robotium [INAUDIBLE].
Which is very, very cool.
MALE SPEAKER: Testing
on 100 plus devices
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, and then you
can upload it to a cloud
or test on a bunch of
different devices.
Any other favorites?
MATT GAUNT: It's just JUnit, I
think is the classic, really.
I think the best bet may be,
start there just for really
local testing.
The Testdroid's awesome for
getting [INAUDIBLE]
devices.
Obviously, there's other things
like DeviceAnywhere and
some other people that do a
similar sort of thing where
you can test on devices,
get sceen shots.
So I think Testdroid adds an
extra load of stuff with it.
If you're just running all
of your own test scripts.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, and
whichever one you choose, even
if you do them all, it all comes
down to the quality of
the test scripts in the end.
Are your test cases valid?
Can you actually get them
to pass and fail?
Are you testing the
right thing?
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE] the
whole hour like that?
RICH HYNDMAN: This isn't me.
This is just what Nexus
10 has come to.
NICK BUTCHER: And yeah, he also
specifically called out--
we should say this is
from powder366.
I'm going to take that to mean
that you're a snowboarder and
therefore awesome.
He asked specifically
about Guice.
I would say--
I can't see.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right.
All right.
NICK BUTCHER: I would
specifically say that I
definitely use Guice
very heavily.
I think at one time the Google
Drive app might have used it.
But I don't know if
that still holds.
Mostly because of the run
time and [? fancy ?]
resolution stuff.
All the reflection APIs
are pretty expensive
on low power devices.
So I don't think we
use Guice hugely.
And there's this new crop of
other dependency injection
frameworks, which are using
ahead of time compile time
resolution.
So stuff like--
what's the one I'm
thinking of?
Auto--
no, that's the bus.
Dagger.
RICH HYNDMAN: Dagger.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
are pretty interesting.
Or Android [? annotations ?]
and stuff like that.
I would say you do some kind
of injection-y type things.
RICH HYNDMAN: And Dagger,
actually by injecting code, so
you can debug as well.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So they compile time.
You can see the code
it spits out.
You can debug it.
And there's no additional cost
on runtime, which is what you
really, really care about.
Not so much Guice.
The other tool, which
is upcoming-- it's
not launched yet.
But we heard about it
a couple weeks ago.
The Square guys, the prolific
open sourcers of awesome code,
are working on a framework
called Spoon, which we had a
preview of.
And [? Jake Watton ?]
from Square gave it a very good
talk at Devoxx a couple
weeks back.
And he gave us a sneak preview
of the Spoon framework, which
should be going open source
soon, which lets you run your
tests across a bunch of devices
and recall the results
off of them and see screen shots
and make sure you're not
breaking your layout on
Device Y or whatever.
So there's some cool
tools out there.
Anyway.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
NICK BUTCHER: Kind of nailed
that question.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
Next [? person. ?]
PAUL HANSON: I've got one
question based on what you
said about dependency
injection.
Has anyone ever used Spring?
Because I heard some
time ago--
Spring being big in Java, but
they were doing some stuff
with Android.
Anyone had any use for that?
NICK BUTCHER: I have not.
I used Spring in my former
life as a J developer.
My gut reaction is it's a kind
of a whole massive stack,
which scares me about all these
things happening at run
time in Android.
I want to make sure
that you're not--
that some developer--
[? conveniently ?]
not sacrificing any
performance or
anything like that.
So I haven't looked
at it in depth.
But I have some sense.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, it's
kind of always sat on
the edge of my vision.
But I've never really paid
much attention to it.
I've not needed to, I guess.
So yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
beta test.
PAUL HANSON: OK, thanks, guys.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, and make
sure it's not doing anything
in run time.
I don't really know what
it's doing because--
be careful there.
So next question from
the moderator.
SPARKY RHODE: Next question
from the moderator.
"I want to perform
an action when a
user is near a location.
I have a proximity alert
on a service that runs
indefinitely.
Is this is good practice in
terms of battery use,
performance, et cetera?" Can
we provide other ideas?
"Does maps check in reminder
work differently, et cetera?"
I think [INAUDIBLE]
has not been a real
strength of our
location API in the past.
Reto published a blog post not
quite a year and a half ago
called Deep Dive Into Location
that's worth checking out.
He calls out things like
passively listening for
location updates that other apps
request that you don't
have to wake up the radios
yourself to do it.
Don't use any finer location
than you need.
If you're still several
kilometers away from your
destination, you don't actually
need to know within
20 meters where you are.
And then, my advice is also just
use some estimation to
reduce the frequency
of your updates.
If you know that's going to be
15 minutes before you get to
your destination, you don't need
to check your location
every five minutes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Reto's Google I/O 2011
talk as well.
Pro tips.
You might as well watch
pro tips too.
MATT GAUNT: Didn't someone open
source the code from that
as well [INAUDIBLE]?
NICK BUTCHER: Two
implementations.
Yeah.
So I think the guys
from Novoda--
RICH HYNDMAN: Novoda
did one, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: --open
sourced it.
Github.com/novoda.
They've got a Novoda-cation--
Novoda location, something
like that--
library, where they basically
took Reto's tons and tons of
awesome best practice code
and wrapped it up
into a library project.
So you can actually just listen
to certain broadcasts
for all these location events.
And there's another one, I
think, as well from the guys
from [? Quite. ?]
So Stefano from [? Quite ?],
think used AspectJ to do a
similar kind of thing, so
compile time using library
project using aspects.
So two implementation of that.
So yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] definitely Reto's
post, specifically just the
case of geofencing.
I wouldn't say having a service
running the whole time
is really the best thing.
You basically want your service
to die as soon as
possible when it's not really
doing any work.
So you probably want to use a
combination of the passive
location provider and inexact
repeating alarms to grab
locations whenever anyone else
fires up the location provider
and also notify your app with
the passive provider.
But then if you need to check
at a minimum interval, like
every 15, 20 minutes, well then
use the inexact repeating
alarms as well.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
I mean, I'm slightly confused as
to why they need to have a
service running all
the time as well.
Because that's kind
of the whole point
of proximity alert.
You're waiting for
something to kick
off, then you do something.
Rather than have it--
[INAUDIBLE]
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, so I think
in practice, right from the
start, there's something that
maybe we're not understanding.
Or perhaps you just need
to think about it
in a different way.
Because of having a service
running all the time scares me
a little bit.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: You can see maybe
running a service all
the time if you're doing
something like opportunistic
location matching.
Say, where am I now
and what points of
interest are near me?
Sort of like the field trip app
or something like that.
Maybe then it makes a little
bit more sense.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
But you're not [INAUDIBLE]
location
the whole time, right?
You want the service to stop
itself as soon as it's stopped
any work and schedule itself to
be woken up again after a
period and then stop itself.
Right?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
And I mean, I guess you'd also
get to a point where you'd
want to use a cell tower
location as just a rough
guide, wait for that to change,
try and listen off the
passive things.
And if you need more fine
grained GPS, then start
perhaps thinking about how you
can try and avoid that.
When you do use it,
use it sparingly.
Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Good advice.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] asked us one
question in the chat.
"How can we access a list view
item field using a simple
cursor adapter that contains a
progress bar, not bind to the
cursor data from [INAUDIBLE].
I should have read while
I read that.
It's a long sentence
after the negation.
"How can I access a list view
item field using a simple
cursor adapter?"
MALE SPEAKER: Can I explain
probably better?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes, sure.
Yes, please.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
In the list view, I have the
items binded with the simple
cursor adapter.
OK?
But I have-- one view more
is a progress bar.
And from a different trait, I
need to access this progress
bar and update the value.
I don't want to update the
database because you can
[INAUDIBLE].
If I want to update the database
each millisecond, I
would [INAUDIBLE] the
access to the SD
card millions of times.
So I want to access just the
view of the list view and get
the item, find the progress
bar, and update.
All of this from a
different trait.
RICH HYNDMAN: So you've
got a list.
And at some point, one of the
items in that list will have a
progress bar going across it?
MALE SPEAKER: Each item has
one one progress bar.
RICH HYNDMAN: You've got
[INAUDIBLE] tasks running.
MALE SPEAKER: They're running
downloading, some downloading.
And I need to refer to
the progress bar
and update the value.
Because the items are binded to
simple cursor adapter, it's
binded with the cursor, I cannot
simply just get the
position or something like that
and access to the view.
MATT GAUNT: But you
can't access--
you don't know which particular
item you want to allow?
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
I ruined one week to
find a solution.
But nothing to do because
from the--
SPARKY RHODE: Maybe--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: But if
he extends list
view and then use--
I forgot the term for it.
SPARKY RHODE: Maybe something
more like a custom view
adapter, where you have your own
code that draws the view.
And at that time, you can--
MALE SPEAKER: No, I'm just
using the regular simple
cursor adapter for
this list view.
I don't use a custom adapter.
SPARKY RHODE: But I'm asking--
MALE SPEAKER: I'm just--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: You can extend
the simple cursor adapter.
And then use it to override the
get view method so it will
fit your needs.
And then if you use a view
container that has the tag for
each item in the cursor,
it can do view get tag.
And then you can--
MALE SPEAKER: Yossi.
Yossi.
Sorry.
Sorry to stop you, Yossi.
I agree with you if we already
decided that the get view or
new view, et cetera.
But not from our [INAUDIBLE]
treat, not from AsyncTask.
OK?
The AsyncTask has nothing
to do with the get view.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No.
You can and add a new method
through the simple cursor
adapter that you extend.
And then from that adapter, you
can get the position and
check the tag.
And if the tag is the same tag
you need from the cursor, then
you can update the view.
You understand what I mean?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Of course I understand.
Yeah.
It's interesting [INAUDIBLE]
purpose.
Yeah.
Is I will try to do that.
MATT GAUNT: I think this
is where probably I'd
instinctively go to solve
that problem.
I would just--
I guess the way you're saying
you don't know which item on
the list you want to update, you
need to find that way of
matching the two up, which
you do in the adapter
one way or the other.
But yeah.
If you extend the simple cursor
adaptor, then you can
start doing a lot
of this stuff.
And it's one of those things
where you have to go to
yourself, is it trying to do
something outside of what the
pre built cursor or the
pre built adaptor
is designed to do?
Yeah.
Just make sure you use the
view holder design path.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
View holder, and also
use hash map or
something for faster using.
And then when you use the view
holder, set the hash map tag
to the same view so you
can find it faster.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I believe that is the
right solution.
I was just looking for something
to not change all of
the structure, not change the
simple cursor adapter with
something else.
Just looking for--
that is why the custom is there,
just to [INAUDIBLE]
all that.
Can I have one more
question probably?
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Any way for a non system
application to write in the
secure settings?
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
NICK BUTCHER: Nope.
MALE SPEAKER: No way.
But is it changed something in
the 4.2 with the settings?
What is it?
What is this?
RICH HYNDMAN: So some settings
were moved to global settings
from system settings.
They didn't obscure them.
So some, you can read and write
system settings, or at
least into the tables.
And some of those items have
now been moved into global
settings where they're
now read only.
The main one of those
is flight mode.
NICK BUTCHER: Some things in
multi user tablets, it just
doesn't make sense to
have a per user
setting like flight mode.
It should about the
global settings.
So there was some refactoring of
where the settings lived to
support multi user.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
So if if you've got a widget
which used to turn flight mode
on or off, now it's best just
to send the user to the
settings screen for flight
mode, to the network and
wireless settings screen.
That's the only place
now that they--
well, that's the place--
MALE SPEAKER: If I understood
well, there are many, many
applications that use a battery
level checker that
must be updated for the 4.2.
Right?
RICH HYNDMAN: Because
it doesn't fail.
All it does is just return
to say that it
didn't write the value.
It's the same situation.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
RICH HYNDMAN: The application
is not going to
throw out an exception.
MALE SPEAKER: Is there any
other way we can save
information to somewhere in the
system, like the secure
that is accessible only from an
application that will write
the information?
RICH HYNDMAN: You're own--
NICK BUTCHER: I don't understand
the question.
RICH HYNDMAN: --shared
preferences?
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
I will repeat again.
I'm looking for somewhere to
write some information.
And only my application
can access this
information, not like--
what?
RICH HYNDMAN: In your own shared
preferences, you can
just-- or any file-- you
can open it as private.
And then it's not accessible
to anyone else.
It's your own--
MALE SPEAKER: Where?
Sorry.
Where is [INAUDIBLE]?
NICK BUTCHER: Multiple of your
own applications or just one
application?
MALE SPEAKER: One application.
RICH HYNDMAN: All the files,
all the data for your
application is protected.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah.
Protected.
When they root to the mobile end
user some explorer, they
can find any files, any
database, anything.
SPARKY RHODE: Nothing's
protected when it's rooted.
I mean, if you want to keep
things so that they can't read
it after the devices
has been rooted--
I don't know--
your own encryption scheme or
something is probably what
you'd have to do.
RICH HYNDMAN: KeyStore API?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, you
might be able to use
the KeyStore API.
I'm not certain.
RICH HYNDMAN: So, yeah.
For the most part--
MALE SPEAKER: Yes?
RICH HYNDMAN: For the most part,
yeah, you just use the
protection that Android
offers you.
But if you're concerned about
rooted users as well--
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I know
that the data over the
application is accessible only
from the application.
But if they use some
[INAUDIBLE]
walk around, they can
find the data.
They can change everything.
And now, if for [? three ?]
last years, 20% of the people
have a rooted phone,
now they are 80%.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
anywhere near that.
NICK BUTCHER: No way.
Less than one.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, I would
definitely say less than 1% of
people have a rooted phone.
MALE SPEAKER: What?
NICK BUTCHER: At the end of the
day, this is kind of moot.
It's not a secure computing
environment, right?
This is a piece of code running
on a user's device, an
untrusted device.
Right?
You can't be 100% sure.
I mean, there's ways
you can help.
Android is a messy [? can. ?]
But at the end of the
day, it's code
running on their device.
If it's super secure, then don't
keep it on the device.
Keep it on the server
or something.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
At any point, anyone could run
this on an emulated or
simulated environment and get
access that data anyway.
So there's not going to be a
place that you're going to be
able to put that to keep
it totally secure.
MALE SPEAKER: Because in one
of our applications, until
version 4.2 of Android, we were
using the encryption AES,
AES encryption.
But I don't know why starting
version 4.2, it's crashing
when we try to--
NICK BUTCHER: I know why.
MALE SPEAKER: You know why?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, there was
a change to secure element.
Some people were making bad
assumptions about how
SecureRandom--
sorry, not secure element.
RICH HYNDMAN: SecureRandom,
yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: How SecureRandom
worked.
I think we have a blog post
coming out on this, right?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
There'll be more information
on it soon.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't have
details at hand.
But yeah.
The implementation of
SecureRandom has changed slightly.
And so if you were making bad
assumptions about how it
worked, then it will
break for you.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: We have seen
a few apps break over
SecureRandom.
NICK BUTCHER: Ping us offline
right now, and I'll try to get
the exact change you
need to make.
But we have a blog
post on this.
MALE SPEAKER: And what do you
suggest doing at this time
until we find the
final solution?
How can we work around the
problem of encryption in 4.2?
NICK BUTCHER: So if your app's
not working, if it completely
fails on 4.2, then I guess for a
temporary measure, you could
set a max SDK on your APK
so that 4.2 users
can't download it.
That would be one way to do
it until you fix the bug.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: I can probably
get offline.
We'll try and--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, we
can resolve this
if it's a huge issue.
Ping us after the show
and I'll send
you some sample code.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
I will do that.
Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Also [INAUDIBLE]
Nexus, there will be a blog
post going out soon making
that available to the
wider audience.
OK.
Somebody has joined
us in the Hangout.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm getting grief
on the comment box for
not wearing a hat.
MATT GAUNT: Yes you are.
NICK BUTCHER: It's
hot in here.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
So you've got the blue.
It is hot in here.
NICK BUTCHER: I guess it's
probably [? sane. ?]
RICH HYNDMAN: It's
why we're facing
this way in the corridor.
Because if you face that way,
it's just sun and brightness,
and you can't see us at all.
SPARKY RHODE: Who said that?
I can't see you.
NICK BUTCHER: Can we get on to
the multi [? printing ?]
questions?
I want to answer that one.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Next question--
MATT GAUNT: Go, go go.
NICK BUTCHER: If there's no
one in there before that.
RICH HYNDMAN: Well,
you can just skip.
Just jump straight to it.
MATT GAUNT: Well, be crazy.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
Rumburak, I guess, in the UK
asks, "What happens to the
worker threads in a pool doing
some network queries to be
displayed on the UI when the
activity is destroyed, eg like
a [? config ?] change?
And what are activities and
tasks described in terms of
Android OS and Linux processors
and users and so
on?"
RICH HYNDMAN: Nice.
NICK BUTCHER: So
good question.
So generally, an Android
application is a user.
There's one user per application
at install time
that you can have.
That's not quite true.
You can actually share the
user ID between your
applications if you set a
flag in your manifest.
But generally, it's one user to
an application and a single
process, which is Random VM.
So when your application
starts, yeah,
the process is started.
It's forked from [? Zyguts ?].
And you get one thread.
So that Java thread,
which maps exactly
to the Linux zThread.
eThread.
RICH HYNDMAN: eThread,
NICK BUTCHER: So then yeah.
But then you have many, many
different ways in which you
can do multitasking
after that.
So when you ask what happens to
worker threads in the pool
doing some network queries,
that's kind of
an open ended question.
It depends on how you create
those worker threads.
I mean, if you're talking
about AsyncTask, which I
suspect you might be, then those
threads will continue to
completion.
But then they won't really have
a context to call back
onto, so those won't
go anywhere.
But if you are going to do your
own thing-- so if you're
going to create a thread
yourself, or if you're going
to use an ExecutorService or an
IntentService or loaders or
any of these good things, then
you have these tasks that
persistently--
destruction of your activity
and recreation of your
[INAUDIBLE].
So it's kind of an open
ended question.
Yeah.
AsyncTask is convenient but not
always the right answer to
your problem.
Take a look at some other stuff
like IntentServices and
handler threads and another
such mechanisms as well.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
[INAUDIBLE].
And don't use your activities.
MATT GAUNT: No.
Never do that.
NICK BUTCHER: So I hope I
answered your question.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
My--
RICH HYNDMAN: What's
that, Sparky?
SPARKY RHODE: My sort of icing
on that cake is if you are
going to run an AsyncTask,
either make sure that you
don't rely on information
from your context.
Or if you do, then when
your context--
i.e, your activity-- goes
away, kill the task.
Kill the AsyncTask
before you do.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I used
to use AsyncTask quite
frequently.
I think because it's
so convenient.
Right?
It's so easy to create and get
these callbacks, which does
all the the marshalling of the
threads-- or mostly-- for you.
But you end up--
if you have to survive rotation
changes and things
like that, you end up having
to write some extra stuff.
So I've actually been more
inclined to use a Handler
thread these days and
pass messages.
I find that you get much more
control over when stuff
happens and how [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I still like the old occasional
in line thread,
just chuck it into
[? random book ?], get it
straight in line,
and come back.
If it just needs to be taken
off the main thread.
NICK BUTCHER: Pro tip, if you're
going to do that, make
sure you're setting
the process.
So if you do create just a
thread, make sure you're
setting the android.os.process,
not the
java.line.process.
It's a bit confusing because
there's two process classes.
So make sure you import the
right one and do the set
thread priority to background.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
And that actually goes into
a background thread in the
kernel as well, which is nice.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE],
yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Happy?
You got to answer the question
you wanted to answer?
NICK BUTCHER: It's
a good question.
I like multi [? thread. ?]
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
I was just about to ask you
if you have a question.
But he's disappeared.
What's up next?
Is there anything coming through
on the G+ thread?
MATT GAUNT: Just lots of
love for the hats.
Lots of love.
NICK BUTCHER: "Are the
hats available
for sale?" says Lionel.
I think they are.
Is it cruzerlite.com?
RICH HYNDMAN: I think
CruzerLite plushy.
If you trying that--
they're here selling them
at DroidCon, Holland.
MATT GAUNT: Come
up to Holland.
RICH HYNDMAN: Come to Holland.
You can get them here.
I think they're 20 euros each.
Or follow Aaron Capo on--
Aaron--
Jesus.
Two wrong names in
one sentence.
I'll remember his name
in a second.
It's Aaron though, right?
On G+.
MATT GAUNT: Aaron Casten?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Aaron Casten.
That's probably it.
That's where they are.
OK.
Next question.
MATT GAUNT: Let's do it.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
So frequent commenter Jan Souza
asks, "How can I do a
horizontal scroll on list view
like the G+ application in
landscape?"
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
a custom layout.
That, you can talk to
[? Chris Benz ?].
He is currently working on
a project to do one.
There are numerous
other projects.
But you're right.
Currently, there isn't a
system widget which we
recommend using to
do horizontal
scrolling on a list view.
NICK BUTCHER: There was some
work on something in the
support library [INAUDIBLE]
chapter on G+.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
is really good.
NICK BUTCHER: And [INAUDIBLE]
is already up.
So I don't know what the
status of that is.
But you might be able to look
at it as the basis of your
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: I mean, Gallery
got deprecated because it
wasn't supported.
And it didn't do things
quite right.
MATT GAUNT: It didn't
[INAUDIBLE] views, did it?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: There are a bunch
of these implementations
of horizontal list view on
GitHub and so forth.
RICH HYNDMAN: I predict you'll
have 10 good implementations
soon instead of none.
There's a few people
working on them.
So just search the community.
You don't have to come to
Holland for that one.
MATT GAUNT: The main one is
just script for one that's
definitely using an
adapter path.
Because one way or another, if
you do that, then hopefully,
whenever the the next
one comes up--
whatever it might be--
it'll still be adapter based.
So hopefully it won't be too
much that you have to change.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: You might want
to take a look at list view
and how it does recycling
as well.
Because that's pretty key
to getting performance.
MATT GAUNT: It does a lot
of crazy stuff in
there, doesn't it?
I swear at one point I started
looking at it.
And yeah.
It's a bit mental.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE] list
view, right, is its parent
that you can extend and
change it somehow.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
MATT GAUNT: The community
will provide.
RICH HYNDMAN: Ask and the
community will provide.
Maybe Sparky.
NICK BUTCHER: Nothing
got next?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Another one there, Sparky?
The next question.
SPARKY RHODE: "Is there any
way to enable multi-user
support on AVD with Android
4.2 and the latest ADT21?
The option in settings
is missing.
And I can't see any option when
creating the new AVD."
Unfortunately, I don't know.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you create--
it must be the case, if you
created a high resolution
device, you've got the
tablet layout.
Creating a high resolution
device means you'd get the
multi user.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know.
There may be some AM
flags you can poke.
So before we launched
multi-user, people had already
found it in JV in 4.1.
And there were some activity
measure settings you could
toggle from the command
line to turn it on.
You could maybe try those.
That's not an official answer.
That's just me.
RICH HYNDMAN: So try making
a bigger emulator.
Seriously.
And yeah.
Have a look back through the
people who managed to
enable it in 4.1.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, yeah.
That's a good point.
They don't specify
whether they've
tried creating a tablet.
Yeah.
So when you created a 4.2
emulator, did you create a
large screen or larger device?
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
I think that's a really
good suggestion.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE] anything
really so you can
mimic devices?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
The new [? NT21 ?]
has a new device dialogue.
And on the second tab, you can
just choose the device that
you want and choose Nexus
10 or Nexus 7 on there.
It would be interesting to
see if it had multi-user.
I love multi-user.
SPARKY RHODE: Unfortunately,
I've gotten lazy.
I have actually not yet
created a 4.2 AVD.
I've been using only devices.
RICH HYNDMAN: Right.
That's not lazy.
That's what you're supposed
to do if you've got them.
NICK BUTCHER: Zeroth
world problems.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
multi-user.
It'd be interesting to see.
NICK BUTCHER: Nico in France
is using one of my favorite
features in Jellybean.
RICH HYNDMAN: What's that?
NICK BUTCHER: The activity
options class, where it lets
you create these nice scaled
animations when you launching
a new activity.
If you have a recents, for
example, where it scales up
from a thumbnail to the full
screen, which I think is a
really, really cool way of
retaining context to the user.
And says, yeah.
They love it.
But how do they do
the reverse.
So you can do this.
You can set a custom
animation.
So you won't be able to scale it
to view or to a bitmap like
you can with the activity
options.
But you can just set a custom
animation to then scale it to
a certain place.
So it's standard activity dot
set pending transition?
RICH HYNDMAN: Override
pending transition?
NICK BUTCHER: Override
Something like this, I think.
So I think you can do that.
So yeah.
You can't do a scale down
to a thumbnail or
anything like that.
But you can get close
to that kind of
behavior using these standards.
Rich is Googling
[? ecstatically. ?]
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
overflow answers come up
before our official
documentation.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
SPARKY RHODE: As long
as they point to our
documentation, it's fine.
RICH HYNDMAN: Chet and Romain's
talk at this year's
Devoxx covered this
exact point.
I don't think those talks are
going live until December.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: And yeah.
It was a three hour
talk they gave.
And there was approximately
400 awesome tips.
So we didn't manage to
remember them all.
But I'll be watching that
and sharing that
talk as much as possible.
NICK BUTCHER: I want to rewatch
that awesome talk.
There were so many
tips in there.
I think I might create a G+
thread and just document all
of those tips.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yossi has added
the Hangout toolbox.
What the hell's going
to happen now?
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
MATT GAUNT: I tihnk Yossi should
just be joining the
Google+ Hangout.
And then he just can pull
out a new Yossi
plugin of the week.
[INAUDIBLE], wasn't it?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Basically it's
every day plugin of the week
[INAUDIBLE].
OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: Plugin
of the week.
[INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Any [INAUDIBLE]
participants?
Who have we got down there?
RICH HYNDMAN: There's
unknown user.
I think that might be--
NICK BUTCHER: Hello,
unknown user.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's unknown
user somehow.
[INAUDIBLE].
Yossi--
NICK BUTCHER: Do you
have a question?
Nope.
RICH HYNDMAN: Nope.
OK You've got something that
you'd like to answer?
Are you particularly excited
about any of the questions?
NICK BUTCHER: Does anyone
understand this
question from Zboarda?
Zboarda asks, "How can you
make a dialog appear as
swiping in a fragment?
I want to show a dialog over
a fragment to mark a multi
valued question.
The fragment is in
a view pager.
How can this be achieved?"
MATT GAUNT: Is it just that you
move the fragment across,
dialog comes up?
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, we can do
that, listing for the view
pager transitions page change?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I think
he doesn't want
the frame to move.
He wants [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: What
are you doing?
MATT GAUNT: But you do get
pulled back when the view
pager's swiped.
At that point you'd want
to bring up dialog.
But yes.
I agree with Nick.
Doing that, then throwing up
a dialog, just from a user
perspective just sounds nasty.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you really
needed to do something which
blocks the interaction
[? tool ?], something had been
filled in, I would probably
have an extra view in your
layout which would show
inside the view pager.
And then have that enabled.
And then they're finished
interacting with
it, get rid of it.
But not actually have a dialog
on top, just have it as a view
inside your layout.
So as you swipe across,
it's already there.
And then they can dismiss it.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm not sure
I completely get it.
A multi valued question.
Is that like multi select?
SPARKY RHODE: I'm wondering
if maybe he means
he just wants to--
you touch it, and it pops up.
These are what you can populate
the field with.
And then it closes down again.
RICH HYNDMAN: Maybe.
[INAUDIBLE].
I don't know.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, that's
what I thought, that the
fragment doesn't really
move in the pager.
Basically, when you touch it,
then you get a dialog with all
the possible options
to choose from.
SPARKY RHODE: It kind of sounds
to me like even your
traditional dialog activity,
the transparent background,
would be just fine.
NICK BUTCHER: So yeah.
I'm not a massive of dialogs.
I don't know.
I'm not a huge fan.
It sounds like what you're
trying to do is like a
multi-step, wizard-y
type behavior.
In which case, you might want to
take a look at some awesome
code which Roman Nurik
shockingly open sourced.
So if you go to code.google.com/
p/romannurik-code.
romannurik-code.
RICH HYNDMAN: Where are
you reading that from?
NICK BUTCHER: My head.
It's up there.
There is a sample.
Or you can look at his G+ feed
from a month or so back.
Or you can go--
RICH HYNDMAN: Probably
search for Roman--
it'll come up.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE],
didn't he?
G+ page.
NICK BUTCHER: Just fumble around
on your computers and
look at his use of
wizard flow.
RICH HYNDMAN: Next
[? seven ?].
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]
wizard hat.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm sure Yossi
could do a Hangout
[INAUDIBLE].
OK.
Next one.
NICK BUTCHER: Should we
issue the next one?
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, Yeah.
Unless there's anything
coming in on--
MATT GAUNT: I'll double check.
RICH HYNDMAN: Is anyone checking
the YouTube comments?
Because they're always
hilarious.
MATT GAUNT: I can do
that right now.
RICH HYNDMAN: And so valuable.
MATT GAUNT: We've got
no questions in G+.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
We're good.
Moderator.
NICK BUTCHER: Moderator up.
OK.
"I have a fragment from the
support library containing a
view with a flip animation
on the y-axis.
It's kind of flipping
a book page.
Page sticks to the finger.
However at 85 degrees,
the view disappears.
Clipped, question mark.
How can I change this?
Or should I use OpenGL?"
RICH HYNDMAN: Wow.
SPARKY RHODE: I'm
just wondering.
Is this just a simple matter
of geometry, that when you
look at a text for edge on,
there's nothing to see?
RICH HYNDMAN: I think so.
Right?
NICK BUTCHER: 85 degrees,
it's almost--
RICH HYNDMAN: At 90 degrees,
it just disappears?
You want it to add
some thickness?
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
I wanted to--
that's why I asked him,
is it just going away?
Or is it a transient condition
that comes back as you scroll
past 95 degrees or something?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I mean, we have 3D rotations.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm also
wondering, is this an issue
with our OpenGL, with
hardware UI?
What I'm wanting to check is
actually just [INAUDIBLE]
accelerated equals false.
And try just to rule out the
possibility that there's some
complication due to
a hardware UI.
Worth checking.
SPARKY RHODE: And then if you
want to get fancy about it--
if you think it might be just
a visual artifact because
you're viewing the page edge on,
then animate a bent page.
Actually make it [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
MATT GAUNT: Let's
put you on mute.
RICH HYNDMAN: Ravi, sorry,
you're going on mute.
NICK BUTCHER: We miss you, Al.
RICH HYNDMAN: We miss you, Al.
Have you got a question
for us though, Ravi,
now that you're muted?
Yes.
SPARKY RHODE: All right.
NICK BUTCHER: Just to finish up
on that on as well, I think
it sounds--
[INAUDIBLE]
SPARKY RHODE: I was just going
to say, dodge the issue by
actually giving the page some
depth, warp it, bend it or
something so that it actually
occupies all three dimensions.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm trying to
work out, is it just a
transition animation?
Or is it following your finger,
in which case you're
using ViewPager, perhaps?
Because if so, then the latest
release of support library
introduced the new class page
transformer, which lets you
apply an effect as
you page in.
So that might actually be
able to create this
same kind of thing.
MATT GAUNT: That'd be cool.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm not if that's
what you're doing.
But if it is, then take a look
at page transformer.
RICH HYNDMAN: Something
weird just happened.
It's the first time I've
ever seen Cedric
without his hat on.
And we're all wearing hats.
The irony.
Cedric from Genymobile--
CEDRIC RAVALEC: Hi.
RICH HYNDMAN: --has come
along to say hello.
[INAUDIBLE]
CEDRIC RAVALEC: I
am on the net?
RICH HYNDMAN: Live, yeah,
to the world.
CEDRIC RAVALEC: OK.
Nice to meet you.
I like this one, this color.
How can I have one like this?
RICH HYNDMAN: They're
selling it in the
partner store over there.
CEDRIC RAVALEC: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: You're
always wearing it.
MATT GAUNT: He's got the cap.
RICH HYNDMAN: He's
got the cap.
CEDRIC RAVALEC: I forgot
it this morning.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm embarrassed.
SPARKY RHODE: Should we let
Ravi ask his question?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, Ravi, what's
your question, dude?
Just unmute first.
Or it's going to be very hard
for the internet to hear you.
MATT GAUNT: We need
to to unmute him?
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
He can unmute himself.
Here we go.
Yeah?
RAVI: Hi, Sparky.
How are you?
SPARKY RHODE: Hey, Ravi.
What's up?
RAVI: Yeah, good.
I like your beard, man.
Right.
I just have some quick questions
about Android
development for application
management with using
[? style of ?]
session managements and stuff.
So is there any factory way to
do session management in
Android just like we do in
Microsoft technologies using
special CS management
servers and stuff?
So is there any kind
of in built thing
which we can manage?
Or do we need to dispatch some
[INAUDIBLE] using a kind of
shared preferences or internal
storage and stuff like that?
SPARKY RHODE: Are you talking
about a session with a stable
application?
RAVI: No.
I mean, if we have a log in--
I mean, we don't have an
external server which manages
the sessions.
But the server only authorizes
the username and the password.
The only thing we need is to
make sure the user is in the
right session.
Or just to make sure if users
do not make any activity, we
can pass to others.
So if an existing session
goes out, the user is
forced to log in again.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
you can just
[INAUDIBLE], and if they--
you can do any number
of things.
It's slightly [INAUDIBLE].
There's a lot of feedback
coming back through.
Is there any chance you've
got any headphones?
SPARKY RHODE: You're not viewing
the Hangout in two
windows, are you?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, yeah.
Or close the YouTube one.
So no.
I don't think there is anything
automatic like you're
asking for which does session
management [INAUDIBLE]
application.
But [INAUDIBLE]
what happens [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
activity.
RAVI: Yeah.
I mean, currently, what we're
doing is we're sorting
everything in a secure
light server.
I mean, a scale like
databases.
And whenever there is not much
activity for a predefined
period of time, and we are
forcing the user to make the
login activity once again.
But I thought if there is any
kind of standard way to manage
everything automatically which
is embedded into the Android
operating system.
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, I think
it's pretty [INAUDIBLE]
without interrupting your
[INAUDIBLE] timeline.
MATT GAUNT: I mean,
[INAUDIBLE]
one use case is when you've
got [INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
a good case, man.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: Thanks, Ravi.
RAVI: No problem.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
OK.
Next question.
MATT GAUNT: I'm starting
to get hot as well.
SPARKY RHODE: I don't know if my
moderator is showing these
questions in the same
order as yours.
Because I think we
skipped a couple.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, really?
SPARKY RHODE: But maybe
they're further
down the line in yours.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
any that we haven't
got to yet.
SPARKY RHODE: Did you get
Cedric from Switzerland?
"Which of the following
Bluetooth Low Energy actions
can we performing in API17?
RICH HYNDMAN: None.
SPARKY RHODE: My answer
was none.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I think so.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
supports low energy profile.
Nexus 4.
But I don't think you can
actually interact with the API
from your application in
any way whatsoever.
NICK BUTCHER: There's no
software implementation.
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
[INAUDIBLE]
Sorry.
SPARKY RHODE: Gabriel Ittner
from Berlin wants to know, "Is
it allowed to send the user to
a website to pay for the app
using Wallet or Paypal or some
other payment method after
maybe using the app for a period
of time for free?"
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
SPARKY RHODE: And I said no.
No.
Google Wallet is the only
allowed payment processor for
apps in Google Play with the
exception of this media
exemption for content which is
purchasable and consumable in
many different places.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
And I know that the next thing
you're going to say is Google
payment services inside an
app [INAUDIBLE] or paid
applications don't support
the country that I want.
So am I still not [INAUDIBLE].
If you wanted to be listed in
Google Play, you have to use
Google Play billing services.
There's no other
option, really.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Can I also add
Google in app payment and also
have Paypal payment
as an option?
Or if the Paypal.
Options is on--
RICH HYNDMAN: It must just be
a Google payment service if
it's just in the Play store.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Oh,
a single one?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Just a single one.
SPARKY RHODE: Of course, the
beauty of the Android
marketplace--
or the Android ecosystem--
is there is more than
one app store.
We don't lock you into just one
channel for buying apps.
And if people prefer to have
other payment options besides
just Google Wallet, then there
are lots of other app stores
they can list in.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, the Google
Android DDA, the Developer
Distribution Agreement,
and also the--
RICH HYNDMAN: Content policy.
NICK BUTCHER: --content policy
that supports this.
It's all spelled out for you.
It says, you must use an
approved payments authorizor.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
It's very clear now that it's
only Google Wallet.
NICK BUTCHER: And that
is Google Wallet.
RAVI: Knock, knock.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: And as if
by magic, it is muted.
I was hoping that someone from
the Dutch Android Usergroup
would walk past so we can grab
them, and they could plug that
awesome Usergroup.
They were founded exactly
one year ago.
NICK BUTCHER: Happy birthday.
RICH HYNDMAN: One conference
ago, I should say, really.
But yeah.
Happy birthday to the Dutch
Android Usergroup.
And if Johann comes back
around, I will
certainly grab him.
MATT GAUNT: They're going
to be watching
the show right now.
So they should be all just
running right now.
And if they're not, then--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, of course.
All the Dutch Android Usergroup
from wherever you're
watching the show from right
now, come and say hello to the
rest of the internet.
SPARKY RHODE: We have just been
joined in the Hangout by
a new member.
Welcome, Paul.
Is there anything you'd
like to talk
about, Android related?
PAUL HANSON: Hi.
Thank you.
I just had one question
in terms of Android.
It's kind of, why the
war on SD cards?
RICH HYNDMAN: Why the
MATT GAUNT: There's
a war on SD cards?
NICK BUTCHER: Attack.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's only
Nexus devices, right?
We just want a good
user experience.
And SD cards have too many
failed user interactions, user
experiences, everything
about them.
There's no good model
for having an SD
card inside a device.
If you're going to start
installing apps to it, you pop
it out, and they no
longer exist.
If we start installing apps to
it, we pop it out, and they
don't exist.
You mount it on another
computer, they generally are
FAT formatted and can't be
accessed from both devices at
the same time.
There's just so many reasons.
NICK BUTCHER: It's not
user experience.
You end up having to get the
user to manage storage, which
is a pretty crappy
user experience.
RICH HYNDMAN: And then at at
some point, you want to
upgrade from a 16
gig to a 32 gig.
And you have to somehow get your
techie friend to manually
copy over everything from one
to the other, including all
the hidden files so things
don't break.
PAUL HANSON: Don't you have to
do exactly that when you buy a
new phone now?
RICH HYNDMAN: Sorry?
PAUL HANSON: You don't have to
do exactly that now when you
buy a new phone?
If all of my stuff is on the
internal storage of a phone--
and I get a new phone because
it's got old or whatever.
I get the next Nexus
or whatever it is.
I have to do exactly that
process that you just describe
there to copy all this stuff
to keep my data from my
existing phone over
to my new phone.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, you do not.
Because you can do a backup
through the Gmail account.
And also you can use the auto
download to all the apps.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: Even if the
copying [INAUDIBLE]--
PAUL: [INAUDIBLE]
background data.
RICH HYNDMAN: --a million other
cases that an SD card
isn't a good user experience
for the majority of users.
They are sought after by techies
and people who like to
carry a lot of content around.
But it's not a great
user experience.
NICK BUTCHER: You had
the choice, right?
RICH HYNDMAN: You
had the choice.
[INAUDIBLE]
PAUL HANSON: I heard a rumor
that future versions of
Android are not going to allow
read/write access to SD cards.
NICK BUTCHER: Wait, what?
You know about future
versions of Android?
PAUL HANSON: Well, I heard a
rumor from someone of a friend
of friend, the kind of thing.
A future version of Android
is going to
disable read/write access.
RICH HYNDMAN: If that did
happen, it would be like the
manufacturer wouldn't be
able to work around it.
I mean, ASUS have managed to do
quite a good job, I think,
of including multiple SD card
support on their devices.
You have the micro SD,
USB slots, all
these different things.
And it works very well.
I mean, it is an platform.
But they can do [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Wait.
Are you actually talking about
the new commission for reading
the SD card?
Is that what you're
talking about?
PAUL HANSON: Possibly.
Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
That's different.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So we did that.
So we've introduced a new
commission as of API16 to
where it's optional, the
permission to read.
Because at the moment--
well, prior to 16, the
SD cards were readable.
And anyone can read
anything on that.
And there were security issues
that ensued because of this
and mistreating it.
So yeah.
We introduced a new
permission.
But so that we didn't break
all the apps and to give
people some time to upgrade,
it's optional at the moment.
So if you have the developer
options, you can go in and
turn it on and enforce
those permissions.
So that only applications with
the read SD card [INAUDIBLE]
write SD card permission can
actually read from it.
But yeah.
In some future release, we've
said that we're going to make
the default to enforce this.
PAUL HANSON: Fair enough.
NICK BUTCHER: So yeah.
It's just that we're giving app
developers some time to
update their apps to ask for
this new permission.
RICH HYNDMAN: But we're
not taking anything
away in this case.
Oh, Cedric's back.
And he's been and
bought a hat.
Cedric's back with hat again.
SPARKY RHODE: All right.
CEDRIC RAVALEC: Hi, guys.
It's wonderful.
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: Is
everything OK?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
We're doing great.
Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Do you
want us to give a
quick plug for AndroVM?
CEDRIC RAVALEC: Yes.
With pleasure.
OK.
Hello to everyone.
So I'm Cedric Ravalec
from Genymobile.
And I'm at DroidCon.
And we are doing a conference
tomorrow on software who's
called AndroVM.
It's an Android virtual
machine on your PC.
So you can emulate your Android
smartphone and tablet
and make all your tests you
want and emulate all the
sensors of the mobile.
And it's a quite famous
open source project.
We have more than 200,000
downloads.
So you can go and help
us to develop it and
to test it for us.
androvm.com.
This is what I can say.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
Everything that helps with
Android testing has always got
to be good.
Especially--
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: We have now also
been joined by someone who's
now one year old.
It's the Dutch Android
Usergroup.
JOHANN: Hi, guys.
NICK BUTCHER: Happy birthday.
RICH HYNDMAN: Happy
birthday to the
Dutch Android Usergroup.
Are you not feeling left
out without a hat?
NICK BUTCHER: Fine.
There we go.
JOHANN: Good to see you from
this side of the camera.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
MATT GAUNT: We need to have
a screen shot of this.
RICH HYNDMAN: How many members
of the Dutch Android Usergroup
now, Johann?
JOHANN: Well, have 330
something members.
But I don't think they're
all Dutch.
RICH HYNDMAN: You should have
done a big push to make it 365
by the one year anniversary.
JOHANN: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you had done
that the last week,
[INAUDIBLE].
20-20 hindsight.
JOHANN: We have a pretty
hardcore group of about 50
during our meetups.
And it's a good amount.
And maybe 20 or 30 who are
always at every meetup.
NICK BUTCHER: And where
do you meet?
JOHANN: Everywhere.
So [INAUDIBLE]
Dutch Android Usergroup.
So there's a lot of activity
in Amsterdam itself.
Of course, we have Amsterdam.
But there are a lot of one man
shows, Android shows, around
the Netherlands.
So there's a lot of activity
in the east and
the south as well.
So I would tend to--
well, not serve them all-- but
I think in December we're
going to have something
about NFC.
We have it in Eindhoven.
It's a bit on the southeast
of the Netherlands.
So it's a good thing.
NICK BUTCHER: And where do
people go to find out more?
JOHANN: You can go to
www.dutchaug.org.
RICH HYNDMAN: Dutchaug.org
NICK BUTCHER: So any dutch
developers out there--
CEDRIC RAVALEC: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: I was
going to say.
And Cedric of course from the
Paris Android Usergroup.
So we're going to plug
PAUG as well.
P-A--
Is it paug.org, paug.com?
CEDRIC RAVALEC: Yeah, paug.fr.
RICH HYNDMAN: Fr.
P-A-U-G dot F-R for the French
Android Usergroup, like 2000
members now.
CEDRIC RAVALEC: Yeah.
Yeah.
And we're working very hard have
also DroidCon in Paris
for next year.
[INAUDIBLE]
MATT GAUNT: It's about time.
RICH HYNDMAN: About
time, yeah.
I think I'm a member
of all three.
London Android Usergroup, Paris
Android Usergroup, and
Dutch Android Usergroup.
NICK BUTCHER: [? We're being ?]
promiscuous.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
usergroups I'm a member.
What about you?
Have you joined them all?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah?
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: Got to catch
them all, damn it.
NICK BUTCHER: So if you
enjoy these Hangouts--
[INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: If you enjoy these
Hangouts talking about
Android development, want to do
them IRL with some Android
developers.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Yeah.
Thanks very much.
JOHANN: Thank you.
NICK BUTCHER: So I think we're
kind of out of time, right?
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE], we've
got three minutes left.
And--
RAVI: So I can do some--
MATT GAUNT: Ravi [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
jump in.
[INAUDIBLE], Yossi?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
You hear me?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
About the GCM, one
quick question.
Basically, the Android model is
that apps are to be put on
the background.
You press the home button, and
the app continues to work
until the system closes down
and the processes is
successfully terminated
by the system.
But if the user presses Force
Stop, then the GCM messaging
won't work on the device.
That's what I saw.
Is that the designed framework
for the GCM to work?
RICH HYNDMAN: Not at all.
No.
The app shouldn't be running
at all anyway
from boot the system.
It should just be going
straight through to
broadcaster receiver, right?
And again, picked up and
starting whichever parts of
your application are needed
to process the message.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
But I'm not getting anything.
Basically, when I press the
Force Stop on the settings--
RICH HYNDMAN: Are you sure
you're not unregistering from
the service?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I'm sure.
Because unregistering from the
service is only when the
application--
we have an exit button on our
app that keeps the device
registered to the GCM.
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, that's
a bad thing anyway.
You have an exit button on your
app that then closes the
GCM connection, did you say?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No.
It doesn't close the GCM.
It keeps the devices registered
and closes all the
other stuff.
So the user basically doesn't
see us on foreground or
background.
We kill the service for the
communication and everything,
terminate it.
And basically, then you
can get a GCM message.
But when I do the Force Stop on
our app, it basically stops
delivering the GCM.
MATT GAUNT: Sounds like
a weird edge case.
RICH HYNDMAN: It is a slightly
strange edge case.
People shouldn't be hitting
Force Stop on apps.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I know.
But basically, you have
users that do it.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, they're
going to do it if they don't
trust your application.
So it seems more like
an app issue.
Then if you've got users hitting
Force Stop on your
application, they're doing it
for the exact reason that they
want to stop it popping
up all these messages.
And it's their only
way, probably.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Basically,
I'm more
paranoid than most people.
So basically, when I use the
phone, every time I don't have
any things on the recent, I go
to Settings and just press
Force Stop on all the
applications.
RICH HYNDMAN: [? I think ?]
Force Stop kills broadcasts as
well, broadcast reception.
MATT GAUNT: Can it be kind of a
back up period, this kind of
Force Stop?
And then [? something's ?]
preventing it from being
restarted so quick.
RICH HYNDMAN: It could
also be that, yeah.
It does sound like--
I generally don't Force
Stop applications.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, me too.
But just for testing,
I did it.
So that's when I found
that issue.
When users complain that
doing the Force Stop--
NICK BUTCHER: It's like when
you [? start ?] an
application, until you run it
for the very first time, it's
in a different status,
isn't it?
SPARKY RHODE: Yes.
It's in the application
stop state.
NICK BUTCHER: Exactly.
I was wondering whether--
[INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: And there's
things you can do
to get around it.
But I don't really want to
suggest them, to be honest.
MATT GAUNT: I don't think it's
probably a good suggestion if
you don't want to suggest it.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
Rich is nailing it
on the head, really.
It sounds like there is some
behavior of Force Stop that
[INAUDIBLE] understand.
And you should try to understand
why your users are
Force Stopping your app.
It might be that--
RICH HYNDMAN: Honestly, if I was
pressing the exit button--
I don't know.
[INAUDIBLE]
just come in.
Yeah, I guess it would
[INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: I would.
RICH HYNDMAN: I guess--
I don't know-- if you changed
the word exit to sign out, it
would make a lot more sense.
Or users would understand
what's it's doing.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
We have the sign out button.
But we also have the
exit button to keep
us working on the--
RICH HYNDMAN: Is that
little Amir?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
Just woke up.
RICH HYNDMAN: Actually, we
shouldn't have woken Amir up
because it is time for
us to quit today.
And we're not allowed to run
over today because there's a
big Android barbecue
to get to.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Thank you guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Cheers.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Have fun.
Have fun.
RICH HYNDMAN: Cheers
to everybody else.
Thanks for joining us today.
And we should be back in the
normal environment next week,
the London office and
the Munich office.
Until next week.
Normal time next week as well,
Wednesday, 2:00 PM.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
Keep Android deving.
RICH HYNDMAN: Keep
Android deving.
Make awesome apps.
MALE SPEAKER: So next week,
the first question will be
mine that you left--